[Musik]
Seite an Seite ohne den geringsten
Zweifel irgendwo südlich von London der
genaue Standort muss geheim bleiben
gefechtstraining für ukrainische
Rekruten die schon bald auf dem
Schlachtfeld stehen werden ist es
Überlebenstraining
sie sind extrem professionell und sie
wissen dass sie wieder an die Front
zurückkehren werden sie wollen so viel
wie möglich lernen wenn Sie also in die
Ukraine zurückkehren sind sie so tödlich
und kampfbereit wie möglich
das gelte schon für mehr als ein Viertel
der rund 20.000 Ukrainer die seit Juni
nach und nach in Großbritannien
ausgebildet werden kein Kanonenfutter
scherzt einer wie der russische Truppen
Nachschub militärhumor
ja
ich werde meine Vorgesetzten fragen wo
ich als nächstes eingesetzt werde
und ich möchte so schnell wie möglich
zurück an die Front
wo ich so viel fürs Schlachtfeld
trainiert habe will ich auch dorthin
mit allein rund 4 Milliarden Euro
Militärhilfe unterstützt London Kiew
dazu kommen hochgeschätzte Erkenntnisse
der britischen Geheimdienste gleich nach
den Amerikanern ist Großbritannien
militärisch die Stütze mit entscheidend
dass sich das Blatt im Krieg in großen
Teilen gewendet hat
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte machen
deutliche Fortschritte und so haben wir
den Fokus unseres Trainings geändert von
Defensive bei der sie sich in statischen
Positionen befinden und versuchen
Territorien zu schützen auf Offensive
den Kampf zum Feind tragen und versuchen
Land zu erobern
Bilder aus den Tagen als die Ukraine
noch mit dem Rücken zur Wand steht als
einer der ersten westlichen
Regierungschefs taucht Boris Johnson im
April in Kiew auf erobert die Herzen
vieler Ukraine im Sturm seine Botschaft
kein Blatt papierpasse zwischen
Königreich und Kiew für das teuflische
Spiel Putins zahlten wir mit höheren
Energiepreisen die Ukrainer mit ihrem
Blut zu Johnson Präsident selenski wird
in kurz vor dessen Rücktritt als waren
Freund bezeichnen das spricht die
patriotische Seite in uns Briten an
obwohl der Ukraine Krieg viele der
Probleme verursacht hat unter denen wir
in Großbritannien jetzt leiden genauso
wie in Deutschland die Inflation die
Sorgen um die Energie und all das andere
auch wenn es zu unserer Misere beiträgt
ist es doch auch für die gegenwärtige
britische Regierung eine ziemlich gute
Ausrede
auch Johnsons Nachfolgerin hat diese
Karte oft gespielt lässt Trucks ihre
Politik sei alternativlos sie selbst
Opfer internationaler Umstände nach nur
sechs Wochen muss sie ihren Rücktritt
erklären
ich habe mein Amt in einer Zeit großer
wirtschaftlicher und internationaler
Instabilität angetreten Familien und
Unternehmen machten sich Sorgen wie sie
ihre Rechnungen bezahlen sollten Putins
illegaler Krieg in der Ukraine bedroht
die Sicherheit unseres gesamten
Kontinents ich wurde von der
konservativen Partei mit dem Auftrag
gewählt dies zu ändern ich erkenne
jedoch an dass ich das angesichts der
Situation nicht schaffe IIK
die Geschichte der kürzesten
Regierungszeit in der britischen
Historie eine in der die ukraine-krise
eine prominente Rolle spielt ein
gemeinsamer Familienabend bei den Skis
wie jeden Abend den ausgehen mal ins
Kino alles unerschwinglich geworden
Sarah arbeitet Vollzeit als
Krankenschwester im ländlichen Dorset
Sam als freier Tontechniker schon bevor
die Lebenshaltungskosten explodiert sind
konnten sie die Familie kaum
durchbringen sie sind seit Jahren auf
staatliche Zuschüsse angewiesen
es ist einfach zu viel was allen
zugemutet wird nicht nur den
Krankenschwestern alles wird teurer und
alle um mich herum können sich das
Notwendigste nicht mehr leisten aber wir
wollen keine Reichtümer wir wollen nur
in der Lage sein notwendige Dinge zu
kaufen und uns und unseren Kindern ein
anständiges Leben zu ermöglichen
voll arbeiten und trotzdem nicht über
die Runden kommen so gehe es
Hunderttausenden Familien eine Bankrott
Erklärung für ein so reiches Land sagen
Sie jetzt gütet die Inflation bis zu 30%
mehr für Grundnahrungsmittel nicht nur
sie Millionen Briten stehen dort
Umfragen an manchen Tagen vor einer
Entscheidung heizen oder Essen ihre Gas
und Stromrechnung hat sich mehr als
verdoppelt nun mit täglich der auch
gecheckt
wir reden jetzt jeden Tag eine Stunde
lang nur darüber wie viel wir heute oder
in dieser Woche für was ausgeben können
das lässt uns nicht mehr los
es ist wie Urlaub wenn man für einen
Moment mal nicht über Geld nachdenken
muss ich mache mir Gedanken darüber was
ich kochen kann lieber ein zwei Pfannen
auf dem Herd statt dem Ofen den ich für
eine Stunde und länger heizen muss die
nächste Sorge ihr altes Auto ohne kommt
Sarah nicht zur Arbeit kann sie Tochter
Daisy nicht zu ihrer Schule für Kinder
mit Autismus fahren
die Kupplung war im Eimer 1000 Pfund
waren fällig wir haben alle Ersparnisse
reingesteckt ohne Auto kann Sarah nicht
zur Arbeit jetzt ist alles Geld weg eine
unvorhergesehene Sache und wir kommen
unter die Räder
wir haben keine Ersparnisse für Notfälle
Null Reserven was ein wenig hilft im
Garten baut die Familie Gemüse an auch
ein paar Hühner halten Sie ob es
trotzdem richtig ist die Ukraine zu
unterstützen eine Frage die in
Großbritannien bislang nicht debattiert
wird
sie sagen uns es ist der ukraine-krieg
deshalb wird alles teurer obwohl wir
mittlerweile so viel erneuerbare
Energien haben bezahlen wir Höchstpreise
dabei sahen nur die großen Konzerne ab
und wir zahlen das ich verstehe nicht so
richtig was da los ist
Großbritannien steht an der Seite der
Freiheit seit Generationen das
historische Selbstverständnis im
Königreich Kritik an der Ukraine Politik
gibt es kaum doch das extra Problem für
die Entscheider zu allen externen
Schocks kommen die hausgemachte
ökonomische Ursünde des Landes so immer
mehr Experten brexitel der brexit allein
kostet uns etwa vier Prozent der
britischen Wirtschaftsleistung die
Pandemie nochmal zwei Prozent und dann
natürlich die Folgen von dem was in der
Ukraine passiert wie schnell können wir
uns im Vergleich zu den anderen Ländern
in Europa erholen es herrscht großes
Rätselraten aber Großbritannien dürfte
es schwerer haben
und als ob das nicht schon schwierig
genug sei im September versucht sich die
Premierministerin mit der kürzesten
Amtszeit in der britischen Geschichte an
einem Experiment Steuern runter dafür
Schulden machen mitten in der
Wirtschaftskrise Fehler für die Trust
mit dem Amt bezahlt
und für die sich der neue intendowning
Street in seiner ersten Amtshandlung
entschuldigt
Sam mistakes es sind Fehler gemacht
worden und ich bin gewählt worden als
Vorsitzender meiner Partei und ihr
Premierminister um diese zu korrigieren
ich werde wirtschaftliche Stabilität und
Vertrauen zum Kernstück meiner Agenda
machen
das bedeutet es liegen schwere
Entscheidungen vor uns
Fehler die einem Mann sein Haus Kosten
dürften dabei seien die eigenen vier
Wände an der Küste alles was er noch
habe Niklas Wilson 65 am Strand in
Hastings mit Minirente und staatlichen
Zuschüssen kommt er gerade so hin wie
viele Briten hat er keine langfristige
Zinsbindung dank Trust erklärt er sei
die Monatsrate für seinen Hauskredit um
umgerechnet 200 Euro gestiegen das kann
ich mir nicht mehr leisten und die
Zinsen steigen weiter so wie ich müssen
Millionen umschulden sie zahlen dann
sechs oder sieben Prozent für
hinauskredit das ist ein
Desasters das von Trust erzeugte Beben
an den Finanzmärkten hat Spuren
hinterlassen bis zu drei Mal so hohe
Kreditzinsen fürs Eigenheim Schulden
machen ist für die Regierung ebenfalls
teurer geworden eine Krise im Kleinen
wie im Großen
ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
meinen Kram zu packen mein ganzes Leben
war ich hier es würde mir das Herz
brechen es ist unvorstellbar ich werde
dagegen ankämpfen solange ich kann aber
es sind so viele Fronten gerade keine
Ahnung wie es endet
im Bodensee wichtig ist also dass wir
nicht wieder in eine Situation geraten
in der die Kapitalmärkte erneut das Land
bestreiten wenn sie so möchten die
britische Politik als unverdaulich
betrachten so vieles hängt an einem
seidenen Faden ich will nicht den
allgemeinen Untergang an die Wand malen
wissen Sie wir gehen durch eine Phase
des Abschwungs wie wir sie noch nicht
erlebt haben und wir wissen auch nicht
genau wie wir daraus kommen sollen
[Musik]
es ist eine lange Liste von Problemen
und Mängel die Großbritannien plagt
möglicherweise sind die Folgen des
Krieges in der Ukraine die großen
Tropfen die das Fass zum Überlaufen
bringen in einem Königreich in der Krise
doppelt so hohe Preise für Gas und Strom
explodierende mieten und der Winter hat
noch nicht mal angefangen
Preissteigerungen dieser Art kennt man
auch in der Türkei wo gerade eine
Inflation von fast 85% herrscht und
tausende Russen die vor Putins mobil
machen flüchten heizen diese
Preisspirale weiter an wie mein Kollege
Lück wahlport berichtet wie ernst die
Lage in Sachen Lebensmittelversorgung
ist zeigt ein Blick auf den Weizen meine
Kollegin Anna Warsberg war in Tunesien
unterwegs wo der Staat den Import dieses
Jahr neuen Goldes kaum noch bezahlen
kann
verliert die Welt bitte nicht aus dem
Blick und ja abonniert unseren Kanal